في كوريا الشماليه الوضع الغذائي يتدهور
كوريا الجنوبيه كشفت عن ازمه غذاء في
كوريا الشماليه الازمه هي الاولى منذ اكثر
من عقدين وسائل اعلام في كوريا الجنوبيه
قالت بان كوريا الشماليه خفضت الحصص
الغذائيه لجنودها كما اقرت فعليا بنقص
خطير في الغذاء اجتماع مرتقب للحزب الحاكم
في كوريا الشماليه لمعالجه الوضع وبحث
انشاء استراتيجيه تهدف لدعم قطاع الزراعه
كوريا الشماليه عانت على مدى العقود
الاخيره من ازمه غذاء وصلت لدرجه المجاعه
في التسعينات
كانت نتيجه للكوارث الطبيعيه التي دمرت
المحاصيل الزراعيه القطاع الزراعي فشل في
تحقيق الاهداف المتعلقه بالحبوب بسبب
الاعاصير المداريه العمل الماضي توفر
الغذاء في كوريا الشماليه انخفض الى مادون
الحد الادنى فيما يتعلق باحتياجات الانسان